à la veille des élections de mi-mandat
le focus du jour nous conduit aux
États-Unis où le débat sur les armes à
largement agité cette année encore la
campagne chaque année environ 40 000
personnes sont tuées par armes à feu
parfois dans des fusillades de masse
comme récemment à ovale des et à chaque
fois la question des restrictions refait
surface illustration au Texas avec ce
reportage de pierre et Laurent et
Valérie de faire
au milieu des fleurs des jouets par
centaines et des croix alignés
depuis 5 mois les abords de l'école
primaire de you Valdi sont devenus un
mémorial improvisé
le 24 mai un adolescent de 18 ans a fait
irruption est tué ici deux institutrices
et 19 élèves depuis ces toute une région
encore sous le choc
[Musique]
je viens de Kyle au Texas
je veux qu'il y ait de vrais changements
et que la violence liée aux armes à feu
s'arrête
le fusil d'assaut utilisé un AR15 avait
été acheté en toute légalité
la troisième fusillade la plus
meurtrière dans une école américaine a
relancé le débat sur les armes à feu en
pleine campagne électorale
ce jour-là justement les habitants de
youvaldi sont invités à rencontrer des
candidats démocrates alors que l'actuel
gouverneur républicain est très
favorable aux armes ici les parents
d'une des victimes attendent des
réponses nous sommes tristes en colère
frustré j'ai quatre autres enfants et je
dois les protéger alors les choses
doivent changer et ce changement c'est
passé l'âge minimum pour acheter un
fusil d'assaut de 18 à 21 ans davantage
de vérification des antécédents des
garde-fous et au bout du compte on veut
une interdiction totale des fusils
d'assaut au niveau fédéral
parmi les candidats un poste local
Javier Casarès le père d'une autre
victime Jacky il s'est lancé en
politique après la fusillade au moment
de prendre la parole l'émotion est forte
[Applaudissements]
reste très mesuré
de confisquer les armes de personnes on
voudrait juste que ce soit un peu plus
dur pour les gens avec ce genre d'idées
à cet âge-là que ça prenne un peu plus
de temps pour obtenir une arme
Caro Texas malgré les drames la culture
des armes est bien ancrée
c'est ici que j'entrepose les armes dans
ma maison
Darwin bodaker collectionne les fusils
depuis son adolescence vs ça c'est un de
mes calibres préférés
c'est une version
6.5
amateur de chasse défend fermement le
deuxième amendement de la Constitution
qui garantit le droit de porter une arme
pour lui les lois qui limitent ce droit
ne changeront rien aux fusillades de
masse
sont diabolisées par la moitié de ce
pays mais ce ne sont pas elles qu'il
faut blâmer
le problème c'est la santé mentale des
gens qui commettent ces actes ignobles
disparaîtrait sans faire de vagues
bien sûr que non il trouvera un autre
moyen
s'il n'a pas intérêt à la moindre
restriction sur les ventes d'armes à feu
c'est aussi parce qu'il organise depuis
22 ans des gunshow des foires aux armes
ce jour-là son salon se tient dans le
hall d'une célèbre chaîne d'hôtel à San
Antonio
plus de 170 tables s'apprête à
accueillir vendeurs et clients
des revolvers des fusil à pompe des
fusils d'assaut nous n'aurons le droit
de filmer que les préparatifs mais ce
vendeur s'attend à un joli chiffre
d'affaires au cours du week-end entre 15
et 20 000 dollars pour ces armes
en 2021 les Américains ont été près de
20 millions d'armes des ventes qui ont
doublé en 15 ans rien que Texas ce
secteur pesait l'an dernier est plus de
5 milliards de dollars selon un syndicat
d'industriel de l'armement et c'est sans
compter sur le marché noir
en Californie la police de San Diego se
bat contre ce qu'on appelle les armes
fantômes
le lieutenant Paul Philipps a même créé
il y a un an une unité spécialement
dédiée à ce fléau
cette fille a un numéro de série mais
c'est une arme fantôme à l'arrière c'est
une gâchette automatique et toutes les
balles contenues dans le chargeur sont
censés partir quand vous tirez une seule
fois des armes trafiquées pour être plus
meurtrières ou pire fabriquer de toutes
pièces à partir de kit ou d'imprimantes
3D HT sur Internet
normalement il devrait y avoir un numéro
de série ici ainsi que sur le côté et là
il n'y a rien le nombre d'armes fantômes
a augmenté de manière exponentielle au
point qu'elle représente 25 à 30% des
armes saisies à San Diego
des armes qu'il est très facile de se
procurer ou d’assembler grâce à des
vidéos diffusées sur Internet comme nous
l'expliquent cet agent qui doit protéger
son identité
ce qui vous faut c'est une ponceuse une
perceuse un nombre minimal d'outils
comme vous pouvez le voir et évidemment
ces armes terminent dans les mains des
gens qui ont interdiction dans posséder
en 25 ans de métiers je n'ai jamais vu
autant d'armes dans la rue je m'occupe
des gangs des zones où il y a beaucoup
d'activités et c'est inédit la facilité
avec laquelle on peut se procurer ces
armes à changer la donne malheureusement
en quelques mois son unité a récupéré
environ 200 armes illégales
un succès pour ses agents mais presque
une goutte d'eau face à l'ampleur du
problème
voilà Paris direct continue avec le
reste de l'actualité internationale
l'actualité sportive c'est journal des
sports regardez